have there been any investigations
as to the connection between remote
viewing and uap so
you can interpret that the way you'd
like wow great question
for um historically yeah that there was
there was some effort
particularly in the in the 70s and the
80s uh
during a program that one of my
colleagues was responsible for
uh the stargate program and before that
it was real flame and before that a
bunch of other names but
uh dr harold budo and can probably give
you some more information on that during
our time in a tip we didn't really
focus on that we were more focused on
the nuts and bolts
but yeah there was you know there was
some some interesting information
that was put out uh in the past about
about that about the
the the connection between remote
viewing and potential uav activity there
was one
uh i think um alleged uh remote viewing
session
where they were remote viewing a
particular enemy target
uh c seaborn a c based target i'm not
going to go into more detail at that
i don't know if i can but apparently
there was some sort of uap
activity associated with that the
problem is when you're talking about
remote viewing it's
it's it's very subjective and so you
have to be very careful
uh when when you're dealing with data
like that because
um it's at the end of the day you need
more information
you need information to substantiate
that's that may be one piece of the
puzzle but
by no means can you put together the
entire mosaic
with just one piece of the puzzle you
need all the pieces to really
really you know understand what you're
looking at
you